like so many other simpsons characters
maggie is fully realized and comes with
her own unique set of quirks
although she can't walk more than a few
steps without falling and rarely speaks
she is one of the show's most beloved
characters
here are just some of maggie's many
great moments
one of the biggest television news
stories of 1995 parodied the biggest
television news story of 1980.
the sixth season of the simpsons ended
on a cliffhanger who shot mr burns
and the seventh season opener promised
to end months of speculation
much like the who shot jr publicity
stunt pulled by the primetime soap
dallas more than a decade earlier
it's assumed that burns's loyal
assistant smithers committed the act
before descending into a boozy stupor
smithers remembers feeling the need to
stop burns and he later finds a
discharged pistol in his coat pocket
police only have two witnesses to the
crime santa's little helper and baby
maggie who reveal nothing in an
interrogation because
well they can't talk however that may be
out of a desire to not self-incriminate
mr burns emerges from a coma and
identifies the shooter as
maggie simpson what happened was that
the awful old guy literally tried to
steal candy from a baby in this case it
was maggie with a lollipop
he fought her for it and in the struggle
his gun fell out of its holster
landed in maggie's hands and
accidentally went off
while recovering in his hospital bed
burns insists that maggie be arrested
however chief wiggum knows better yeah
right pops no jury in the world is going
to convict a baby
maybe texas each member of the simpson
family has a few
distinguishing characteristics for
example
bart is a troublemaker marge is totally
square and
maggie doesn't speak that's partially a
function of her being a baby but
a whole lot of comedy can be mined from
a character who's very intelligent but
stays silent
however maggie does speak from time to
time and it's on such rare occasions
that when it does happen it's a
certified tv event with a big celebrity
lending their voice to the role
the 1992 flashback episode lisa's first
word
features lisa as a newborn baby and it
ends with homer putting maggie to bed
and quipping that he hopes she never
talks so that she'll never talk back to
him
after he leaves maggie delivers the
magic moment
making maggie's first word even more
impressive is that it was
voiced by guest star elizabeth taylor
then in the 1994 treehouse of horror
segment time and punishment homer
careens through different realities
landing in one where maggie kills
groundskeeper willy with an
axe and that's when she speaks again
only this time in the voice of james
earl jones
this is indeed a disturbing universe
marge finally cracks under the stress of
managing a household and
raising three kids with no help from her
husband in the 1992 episode homer alone
necessitating a trip to rancho relaxo
remember you can't spell relaxo without
relax
but marge doesn't trust homer to watch
the children for even a couple of days
and she shuttles bart and lisa
off to the sad apartment of aunts paddy
and selma however
maggie is smart enough to know that's a
bad scene and she refuses to leave home
despite marge's reservations maggie
stays with homer
she was right to worry though because
homer and maggie are lost without her
maggie is just a baby after all and she
doesn't understand why her beloved
mother suddenly disappeared albeit
temporarily
so after homer puts her to bed and
almost immediately trashes the house
with barney she crawls out of her crib
out through the doggy door and into the
springfield night in search of marge
on the surface this is a plot about a
baby wandering the streets in the wee
hours but it's not too troubling because
the simpsons is a family cartoon
and maggie is surprisingly
self-sufficient
the running gag for most of the episode
is that springfield is full of things
and people that look
like marge and get maggie's hopes up
including a shrub
a giant ice cream cone sign and a guy in
a beefeater hat working at a
british-themed quick lube business
move job while you white don't touch me
as the youngest least mobile and almost
completely silent member of the simpsons
family
maggie is rarely the center of a main
plot or subplot of an episode of the
simpsons a show that despite being
animated and where time doesn't pass and
people don't age
trades in realism however maggie gets
her rare chance to take center stage in
a delightfully surreal way during the
2015 episode puffless
closer in form to one of the simpsons
themed theatrical shorts the episode's
secondary plot known as maggie's
extraordinary animal adventure is a
self-explanatory
self-contained lark in which maggie
makes friends with a squirrel outside of
her bedroom window which is her entry
into a secret world of adorable critters
including an owl opossum and
duffman's pet parrot maggie takes charge
and saves the day when local yoko cletus
traps the opossum so he can cook him up
and feed him to his large family
hey brian day i called us a possum
you wanna name it before we eat it or
after
daring thanks to maggie the friendly
opossum is freed after a full-on assault
from the springfield animal community
and it's all done without anybody
speaking a word which is great news for
maggie and the animals but it's a
serious disappointment for cletus's
kids okay well uh possum's gone
but you got fingernails to chew on who
knows what's under them
the 1992 episode brother can you spare
two dimes staged a reunion between homer
and his half-brother herb powell he was
left homeless and eating out of garbage
cans after homer's failed car design
bankrupted his automobile company
so how does maggie play into this
narrative well the simpsons was barely
into its third season but it hit
so big and thoroughly that fans were
already clamoring to find out what was
on the mind of the baby of the family
they got their chance when uncle herb in
an attempt to restore himself to a
wealthy lifestyle invents a machine that
translates baby talk into plain english
he does it with the help of a 2 000
investment from homer
the almost always silent maggie talks a
lot in this episode or at least
she babbles like a typical baby but
thanks to herb's brilliant invention
everyone can finally understand the
complexities of maggie's deepest
thoughts
i have soiled myself how embarrassing
through a series of strange events and
misunderstandings a 1995 simpsons
episode finds the county visiting homer
in marge's home and deciding that
they're unfit parents
the kids are immediately placed in a
child welfare van and driven to a foster
home
hey leho welcome to your new home
neglectory knows
while the episode is primarily a bart
and lisa adventure focusing on the two
older simpson kids as they miss their
parents and struggle against the creepy
vibe of flanders tv restricted
environment
maggie shines in a big way throughout
the story she's the reason government
agents ultimately decide to reassign the
simpson kids as she's found wearing a
sign bart originally placed on lisa's
back reading i'm a stupid baby
and one of the big twists of the episode
is that maggie really responds well to
her new lifestyle relishing in the
attention bestowed on her by the
flanders
at one point she even removes her
pacifier so she can babble and call ned
daddily doodly luckily the spell is
broken when she finally sees her mom
oh maggie you're a simpson again
[Music]
1992's a streetcar named march finds
march starring in a community theater's
musical version
of the extremely dark tennessee williams
play a streetcar named desire
but because homer is such an oafish lout
she has to bring maggie along to
rehearsals
after maggie disrupts an intense scene
between marge and ed flanders the place
director llewellyn sinclair forces marge
to drop her off at his sister's daycare
center
the ein rand school for tots inspired by
the philosophies of rand
sinclair runs a harsh school that
promotes stark individualism and
encourages children to develop the
bottle within which includes
confiscating all pacifiers
that's a big problem for pacifier
addicted maggie who try sucking on her
thumb
crayons blocks and anything else she can
get her little hands on
eventually she attempts to break into
the locker where the confiscated
pacifiers are stored
however she gets caught in the act and
thrown in the box
a playpen equating solitary confinement
the centerpiece of the bee plot
a grand parody of the great escape soon
commences
maggie brilliantly sneaks into the
daycare center's vent system and lowers
herself into
miss sinclair's office with the string
from a talking krusty the clown doll
she then grabs the keys to the pacifier
locker and uses a makeshift zipline of
her own devising to access the forbidden
treasure
despite the odds maggie's plan works
even better than expected
maggie time to go to the
a 1997 episode of the simpsons my sister
my sitter looks into how funny it can be
when maggie acts like an actual baby
at the beginning of the story lisa
proves herself to be such a dependable
and mature kid that she becomes a
successful babysitter
what do you say homer can lisa babysit
for my kids please please please
i'll have to ask her
homer and marge even trust her to look
after bart and maggie when they head off
to the fancy grand opening of
springfield south street squid port
shopping district
the idea of younger lisa in charge
enrages bart
and he sets out to make the night as bad
as possible for his babysitter refusing
to eat dinner and getting ice cream
all over himself that fake tantrum
provokes a real one
in a stress sensing maggie and bart
gives her ice cream to calm her down
one problem it's coffee ice cream it
jacks
up maggie into a twitching grinning
wide-eyed caffeine monster who crawls on
the shower curtain rod sprays talcum
powder on lisa and runs off
after bart knocks himself out lisa has
to safely get the whole crew across town
to dr nick riviera's sketchy clinic
since maggie is so thoroughly and
hilariously agitated from the coffee
lisa puts her in a cat carrier because
she won't stop sticking her fingers and
passed out bart's face
and as a grim finale she intends to
drown that poor cage baby
maggie often seems to be off doing her
own thing and she's mentally and
physically separated from her older
verbal family members
that idea persists in the many future
set episodes of the simpsons
in which maggie is the only one in the
family who's both successful and
at peace with herself homer seems to die
an awful lot
bart winds up a destitute bar musician
lisa is president but stuck in bad
relationships
all while maggie is off living the life
she wants to live and doing so as early
as age 9.
in future drama she isn't home on bart
and lisa's prom night
instead marge shows off a moving photo
of maggie waving from a beach in alaska
she doesn't speak a word as is the
simpsons way with maggie
audiences also don't hear a sound from
30-something maggie in holidays of
future past
by which point she's become a world
famous rock star
amusingly future maggie is also the
eventual mother of a quiet baby who
looks exactly
like her mom so who's the father
yeah it doesn't matter disney welcomed
the simpsons to its disney plus service
in 2020 with a short titled play date
with destiny
in this completely dialogue free story
marge takes maggie to
not responsible for injuries park where
she meets a cute boy that viewers learn
is named hudson at least that's the name
written on his diaper
it's love at first sight as they hit the
various park attractions
maggie and hudson imagine they're
engaged in grand romantic activities
horsey spring riders becoming real
horses a drinking fountain doubles as
champagne for two
and dining in paris is in reality
sharing sand in the playground
it all ends during a game of peek-a-boo
when maggie is surprised and heartbroken
to see hudson's mom loading him into
their car
after a good night moon themed dream in
which everything turns into hudson's
face
maggie preps for her next playground
date only to find to her
horror that homer is on kid duty
unfortunately he takes her to a skate
park because they've got a taco truck
the next day maggie doesn't take any
chances and wrestles control of the car
away from homer and drives them to not
responsible for injuries park
it's there that she finally reunites
with hudson for their first kiss
well more like a baby version of a first
kiss
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the simpsons are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you